so in those early days when you made
that decision had your conversation with
your parents was it easier to book
acting work or modeling work or to
different animals modeling work
primarily because I had a modeling agent
before I had an acting age in New York
so they were able to get me out and get
me print jobs and some some commercial
stuff and that paid the bills and that
was a blessing because that was that
gave me the ability to go take an acting
class and not wait tables you know it
gave me time to go work on the scene
with someone instead of waiting tables
so that would that was that was a
blessing and the modeling work is it's
easier it's there's no lines you're
trying on clothes you're looking pretty
it's not it's not really that hard
the acting work is the stuff that takes
time and effort and is a lifelong
journey
whereas modeling is you look good you
don't look good or you look right for
some campaign or you don't you know it's
very kind of you go in there and they
book your they don't it's not you know
it's not acting
are there different modeling looks for
LA versus New York I don't know if
there's modeling in LA I haven't really
done any model I booked a corona print
ad which is which was cool but I feel
there's more modeling in New York and
that's one thing that kind of sucks
about LA but I came here to act not here
to model you know I didn't really go to
New York to model the first place I
happened to book a few modeling jobs and
some commercial stuff which is great but
I didn't move to New York to be a model
how did that happen
New York what the modeling um this is a
secret I was a working fit model for
seven years in New York City I don't
know if you know what a fit model is
people automatically think it's like
fitness modeling now you're shredded
you're you're lifting weights and you're
on the covers of magazines so a fit
model is someone your shirt for instance
who is it designed by whatever yeah
Karen clothing right so when Karen
clothing made that that blouse oh that
shirt they before they can actually
produce it and put it in stores they
have to fit in on somebody okay so let's
say gap made this t-shirt I used to work
for Gap so I
and say that gab made this t-shirt right
so if they want to sell it they have to
try it on a fit model size 32 about 511
170 pounds and they have to try every
single piece of clothing on that
standard fit model
I was lucky for some reason apparently
jeans fit me perfectly and and I'm just
like apparently a perfect size 32 so I
was able to do that with a bunch of a
bunch of fit modeling clients in New
York which paid a ridiculous amount of
money so I was able to pay my bills
doing that very lucky very lucky how did
you get that gig I wet my agency was
like you ever do fit Molly I'm like I'm
not really that Jack they're like no
dude it's not about fitness it's like
you try and close Mike okay I got my
first my first client plug jeans and
they hired me and we're paying me by the
hour a ridiculous about it my name is
steady because it's like they look at
the jeans they don't fit they're like
what's wrong with these jeans I'm like
well they suck they suck here they suck
here this doesn't fit this doesn't fit
okay they take the gene they send it to
China
get it fixed adjusted send it back all
right
meet Michael again try the gene again
and they did that with every single
piece of clothing so it was steady work
it's not many people know about the
industry but it's and some of the you
know makes the most money the plus-size
girls forget it they were getting paid
$300 an hour so how does someone find
those jobs go find a modeling agency in
New York that does that I actually was
lucky to stumble upon one and I had good
people working for me so they really
gave me at one point I had about nine or
ten pretty top clients using me for for
denim and for four tops mostly denim
apparently my ass is perfect for jeans I
I don't know man it was really awkward
my first the when I was doing the fit
modeling cuz it's just like they're like
touching you it's like really and this
happens really yeah I feel like a piece
of meat absolutely oh absolutely but you
know it's I had fun with it I just I had
fun with it and they're paying me so I
was like shut your mouth and you let
them know if they touch your knee in a
weird area it makes you laugh you deal
with it right but then eventually you
progressed and they wanted to see all of
you yeah yeah yeah
like oh well you look decent in in tops
too so I did that I don't know I guess I
should thank my parents they gave me a
perfect size yeah thank you mama
you